et bien voilà la chaîne a qu'un 10000
abonnés c'est formidable parce que quand
j'ai lancé cette chaîne ya maintenant je
ne pensais pas que ces petites vidéos
qui était au départ destiné à mes élèves
seraient accueillis de cette façon par
tous les spectateurs que vous aide et
par toutes les personnes qui suivent
cette chaîne dont je vous remercie pour
votre soutien
pour votre bienveillance et je vous
propose l'exercice classique des chaînes
qui atteignent les 10000 abonnés c'est
la foire aux questions donc si vous avez
des questions sur nous poser certaines
choses par rapport à cette chaîne ou aux
sciences sociales n'hésitez pas à les y
lâchez vous dans les commentaires et on
organisera une petite vidéo pour y
répondre voilà je vous remercie encore
et je vous dis à très bientôt dans une
prochaine milieu
[Musique]